[Musique]
c'est un sujet dont je voulais parler
avec vous parce que je le trouvais super
intéressant et je vous en ai parlé ce
matin sur twitter lors du lightswitch
d'ailleurs si vous ne l'avez pas encore
rejoint son fruit nous invite à le faire
je mets le lien en bas dans la
description cliquez dessus on parle tous
les jours d'actu enfin pour complet
revue de presse on regarde les
différents médias français à dallas où
l'on regarde ce qui se passe du côté de
la deûle attaques internationales c'est
super intéressant donc aujourd'hui
surtout richie un sujet dont on a parlé
que je trouve extrêmement passionnant et
bien c'est facebook et instagram qui
pourrait devenir payant alors attendez
vous expliquent qu'ils sont pas arrivés
ou dans vous allez payer non c'est pas
ça
en fait c'est pour réagir à la mise à
jour apple la mise à jour de ios 10.4 10
je ne sais plus la mise à jour d'ios 14
points mais voilà j'y suis je reviens la
mise à jour de l'ios 10 14
la bâche c'est dur la mise à jour d'ios
14.5 qu'est ce qu'elle fait et bien être
vous permet de venir bloquer le tracking
des différentes applications et
notamment le tracking de facebook et
d'instagram alors facebook et instagram
appartiennent au même groupe je passe un
petit peu de tout et je fais extrêmement
rapidement et qu'est-ce qui se passe eh
bien il se passe en fait c'est se couper
de revenus publicitaires parce que
comment fonctionne facebook et instagram
il fonctionne par la pub
oui en vous suivant ils vous suivent là
où vous allez il regarde ce qui se passe
ils permettent de vendre en tout cas vos
données personnelles à différents
partenaires avec lesquels il travaille
pour savoir ce que vous voulez acheter
si vous voulez acheter un nouveau jeu ne
vous allez voir une pub d'un vélo
s'afficher et compagnie essayer ça c'est
un peu le même principe que ce que
propose google au niveau du tracking
publicitaires sauf que sauf qu'eux et ça
c'est super intéressant
facebook et instagram sont montés au
créneau il en est à ta ta ta ta ta non
non non et non parce que si vous faites
ça eh bien il se peut que facebook et
instagram devienne payant alors je ne
sais pas si vous vous souvenez il ya
quelques années en arrière
facebook avait marqué pendant très
longtemps en bas tu serais au social
lorsque vous allez vous inscrire
facebook est gratuit et le restera pour
toujours
alors aujourd'hui c'est plus écrit ses
plus réellement le cas et on essaie de
comprendre un peu ce qui se passe alors
ce qui se passe ça vient bien alors on
regarde
tout ça c'est un média international que
je vous invite à découvrir si vous ne
connaissez pas qui s'appelle the bear
j'ai eu peur j'étais vachement bien
qu'est ce qui nous dit dans dans ce
verger nous explique facebook qui les
installent g
ils réagissent enfin et à ce qui s'est
passé au niveau des os 14.5 et ils sont
pas contents et regardez la photo vous
le voyez là c'est un message qui est
apparu lors d'une mise à jour
hop là on le voit bien écrit ici sur
facebook mais également sur instagram
elle qui facebook free of charge aide
qui instagram free of charge et des
permettez à ce que facebook est est ce
que instagram reste gratuit donc la
question c'est si vous voulez que
facebook et instagram reste gratuit vous
devez accepter qu'on vous suive
vous devez accepter que votre vie privée
eh bien on puisse l'utiliser pour la
monétiser auprès partenaires alors ce
système n'avait pas tout nouveau
intention c'est par facebook il a
révolutionné ce stade-là existe depuis
longtemps ce notamment le business model
de google google vous met tous à 10 pour
gratuit les e-mails les compagnies
pourquoi pour avoir vos data pour
pouvoir les revendre les monétiser et
que vous ayez de la publicité ciblée
c'est la publicité ciblée
maintenant ça va poser une question je
me suis dit je vous la pose à nouveau la
question dites le moi d'ailleurs en bas
en commentaire ce que vous en pensez
est ce que vous serez prêt à céder un
peu moins de vos données personnelles a
lâché un peu moins d'informations sur
votre vie privée pour avoir un peu plus
justement de vie privée et est ce que
vous accepteriez de payer les réseaux
sociaux est-ce que vous accepteriez de
se dire ok ok ok ben moi j'ai pas envie
de facebook me suis moi j'ai pas envie
casta g de sucre mais pour autant le
service vendent bien et j'ai envie de
continuer d'être dessus est ce que je
serais prêt à payer 5 euros 2 euros
voire un peu plus je sais pas pour
pouvoir continuer à l'utiliser mais
qu'il n'y ait pas de tracking comme ce
qu'on peut avoir notamment sur youtube
avec youtube premium vous avez youtube
gratuit avec la publicité et vous avez
le youtube premium sans publicité est ce
que vous seriez prêt à avoir et utiliser
un youtube et facebook premium et un un
style sommes prêts à les marquer le
moment pas parce que ça serait vraiment
des questions super intéressant parce
que depuis l'avènement d'internet on
tu es ce que tout soit il a clairement
été gratuit enfin aujourd'hui quasiment
tout est pas gratuit pour tout le monde
puisque des gens qui payent derrière les
serveurs coûte cher les stèles coûte
cher les développeurs vous car tout
coûte cher mais pour vous c'est gratuit
mais c'est pas gratuit parce que vous
devez concédé vous un peu de votre vie
privée est un peu de vos données
personnelles alors elles seront
utilisées comme quand elles sont
utilisées je vous dire ils sont pas en
train de pâques après derrière contraint
de regarder ce que vous faites ce que
vous mangez à l'instant t mais malgré
tout il ya des bottes qui regardent et
qui font mal chez de la publicité par
rapport à vos seins à vos centres
d'intérêts il ya toujours un côté un peu
problématique quand on y pense quand on
se dit mais c'est vrai qu'en fait ma vie
privée et elle est étudiée par sega fans
par ces géants américains à des fins
commerciales
alors moi je n'ai pas forcément envie de
ça de l'autre côté je suis pas prêt à
payer donc la question c'est seriez-vous
prêt à payer ou alors à contrario ce que
vous dites est dès lors que ça devient
payant word doc moi j'ai pas envie de
donner toute ma vie privée bien je pars
je parte ces réseaux je me casse
allez je m'en vais faire mes bagages
demandé est ce que vous seriez prêt à
faire ça c'est super intéressant
et alors je pose une analogie quand on
en parlait surtout de ce matin c'est sa
part être un petit peu ça enfin que vous
voulez c'est avec la révolution
d'internet
on a l'impression que tout est gratuit
qu'on peut tout prendre pour tout ont
possédé et la musique est un très bon
exemple
avant quand on consommer de la musique
ont acheté des cds peut-être les gens
qui le font qu'au regard des gens dit il
a probablement des gens qui le vaut ce
nom des rayons cd n'existerait plus mais
en tout cas beaucoup moins qu'elle n'ait
pas en quel une époque si vous voulez la
musique soit vous l'écoutiez la radio
nous enregistré sur une cassette et j'en
parle dit à très longtemps soit vous
avez vous acheté le cd et vous mettre à
votre platine quand internet est arrivé
on a vu passer des napster des idiomes
qu'est le truc comme ça où on et
télécharger en toute illégalité pas que
c'est bien je dis vraiment toute
illégalité et bien sa musique n'ont
jamais pourquoi est-ce que je paye est
bonne pourquoi est ce que j'ai répété
c'est gratos et ont raté c'est à gratot
si on le sait on le sait et on a vu
arriver des services comme spotify
deezer apple musique tu me dis les
compagnies qui vous font payer vous un
abonnement pour vous puissiez
effectivement écouter de la musique
on paye un petit 10 euros par mois et
ont accès à un catalogue gigantesque
avec moi je me sens très bien
si bien que ça permet de faire vivre les
artistes difficilement parce qu'elle
touche pas beaucoup d'argent quand même
c'est pas énorme et malgré tout vous
payez vous participez pas alors l'idéal
est là
est ce que vous seriez prêt à faire la
même chose pour votre consommation sur
facebook et sur instagram
extension sur les différents réseaux
sociaux c'est-à-dire snap chacun tik tok
est ce que vous seriez prêt vous à payer
allez on pourrait se dire j'en sais rien
facebook par exemple je vais avoir accès
à un fil d'actualités à voir ce que m
mes amis et avoir quelques médias mais
pas les vidéos
allez je paye 5 euros droit d'entrée
tous les mois abaca la vidéo ça
m'intéresse bien j'ai bien envie de voir
ce qu'ils en vidéo ça me fait marrer je
veux rajouter deux euros de plus qu'il
ya sept euros par mois je me donne
vraiment une idée comme ça en fait ça
pourrait on pourrait dire c'est
intéressant d'avoir un paiement par
tiroirs on paye anti roi ou alors un
paiement mensuel vous payez temps vous
avez accès à tous all in je sais pas ça
c'est vraiment ça me questionne et cette
notion de vie privée de donner notre vie
privée en pâture à des entreprises pour
générer des gains et pour vous offrir un
service toujours un peu la même question
alors je moi je partage dans mon compte
ne partage pas une chose aujourd'hui sur
youtube sur nietzsche fait les lives
juste me permet de vivre et je sais
comment ça marche je comprends tout ça
c'est évident mais malgré tout cette
question de la vie privée que moi qui
suis consommateur aussi d'écouter venu
quand même est ce que j'ai en oublie que
cocon sage que je sais moi j'ai envie
d'acheter la planche mais moi je voulais
acheter une plancha soit au lit dès les
beaux jours reviennent à ce que j'ai
envie que vous je tombais est ce que
j'ai envie qu'on sait ce que je veux
acheter une plancha binger suis pas sûr
a très grave une plancha
mais si on suit pour la plancha est ce
qu'on ne suis pas sûr des e-mails
l'hyper perso que j'écris à ma banque
est-ce qu'on ne suis pas sur mes
conversations privées que j'ai d'être ma
famille les loyers il ya toutes ces
questions là où s'arrête le tracking
c'est quand même très compliqué en
termes d'utilisateurs de le savoir donc
ça soulève pas de questions je voulais
en parler avec vous c'est un peu sur le
vif comme ça ça mène toutes ces
réflexions dites moi ce que vous en
pensez est ce que vous seriez pas pu ou
pas moi je sais pas mais en tout cas je
me dis que ça se réfléchit ça se
réfléchit parce que rien n'est gratuit
tout se paye soit vous payez avec votre
vie privée sur vos collègues votre
portefeuille parce que vous en pensez en
vrai ce que vous seriez prêt vous à
payer oui non dans quelles conditions à
quel tarif
qu'est ce qui vous paraît très être
juste sur quels services vous iriez
parce que si on se disait ça ok on va
dire aujourd'hui facebook instagram bon
aller et même ô combien il devenait
payant les demandes jeu par des deux je
vais sur un équivalent on prépare des
plates formes
mais quel business model il on est
derrière c'est toujours un peu compliqué
au ciment pourrait se dire ok ok hockey
lnh part je pars sur un tick tock il
m'affiche de la publicité j'accepte je
vais chez google sur youtube il
m'affiche de la publicité j'accepte
n'existait de la publicité traquer une
fois de plus si elle est patraque et est
ce que les annonceurs continueront
rester est-ce que ça les intéresse
est-ce qu'ils paieront un peu moins cher
pour être présents parce que c'est plus
diffus comme ce qu'on a aujourd'hui à la
télé un voyage il ya toutes ces
questions qui se posent quoique encore
la télé aujourd'hui commence où sir la
publicité ciblée notamment par rapport à
votre ip grâce au bob ces compagnies
n'ont encore un autre débat mais cette
question il se pose mais si donc on
voyait arriver une autre plateforme en
face c'est ce qu'on irait tout autant de
succès que ce ne serait pas la mort des
réseaux sociaux
de ce point de vue là est ce que vous
trouverez les ça bien
d'un autre côté les réseaux sociaux
c'est un moyen d'expression les partages
extraordinaire il ya des trucs qui sont
un terrible un gain de tous il ya des
travers est positif et négatif malgré
tout les réseaux sociaux a permis de
libérer des paroles me to notamment mis
tout inceste a beaucoup de choses qui
sont libérés grâce aux réseaux sociaux
qui aujourd'hui sont gratuits grâce au
fait qu'on vient monétiser votre vie
privée
voyez le truc quelque chose positive des
choses négatives voilà c'est ça c'est un
sujet très vaste et très complexe mais
en tout cas ce qui est sûr et ce qui est
intéressant c'est de voir de quelle
manière est ce que facebook aujourd'hui
je viens viens taper du poing son talent
les on attend des utilisateurs d'apple
on vous a vu arriver avec vos iphone
vous voulez pas payer
non non non et bah alors vous allez
devoir passer à la caisse
c'est pas possible ça peut pas
fonctionner et ça aujourd'hui cette
nouvelle fonctionnalité sur ios 14.5 l
arrivée d évidemment sur vos iphone mais
également sur vos ipad ipad ios ipad ios
14.5 voilà moi ce que vous en pensez
c'est un très grand débat c'est un très
grand débat moi je trouve passionnant à
les autres se chauffer vos bijoux
petit aparté et on se retrouve dès
demain pour continuer à parler avec bien
évidemment des bisous
tout ça demain ciao